so James I want to start with you
because Justin brought you this idea for
a film
how long ago and was basically the movie
that we see up here or Justin and I've
been throwing back and forth an idea
about doing a film based around the LA
riots for about four or five years now
and originally it was supposed to be a
straight comedy and it and it evolves in
30 years into a drama with comedic
elements okay and was his pitch always a
little bit inspired by what happened to
his father and we should reference who
his father is in the film and what
happened to his dad who wants to take
that absolutely Justin this father owned
a shoe store warehouse in Paramount
California which is kind of loosely the
store in this film is based on and
Justin's biological father was a former
child actor from Korea and Justin was
able to convince him to come out of 40
years retirement and play mr. Kim in
this film so family affair David did you
know Justin much before this how did he
track you down yeah so Justin I've been
friends for five six years at that point
now we should do like small little
comedy sketches on my YouTube channel
here and there and then he approached me
about this film about a couple years ago
and he had wanted to do a film with me
for a while just didn't know where he
wanted to put me and when he originally
approached with this he was talking
about the Le Raya film and then he kind
of brought up because I will do you want
to help me co-writing and co-directed I
was like no let's take some baby steps
first you know and then you know he kind
of just it just kind of like organically
grow to the point where I read the
script I was like let's do this one of
the things that's obvious about this
film is that the authenticity with which
you cast it is palpable there are a lot
of people who are either
non-professional actors or actors for
the first time so we have to talk about
how you found miss Simone over here so
what was your casting process like and
how did you find her some we're gonna
ask you about your first audition but
what were you looking for and how how
did your path lead you to her
so was Camila character Justin I knew
that that was gonna be the pivotal role
to cast for this film and we're
really worried about it and we went the
traditional route I'm going to casting
agencies and casting director friends
and we were auditioning you know the the
pool of girls from the Nickelodeon
Disney sitcom world and you know it's
just just whether they're coming into
rehearsal auditions and mingling and
it's just working you know so at that
point a mutual friend reached out to
introduce us to some community centers
and the Fernando Coulomb community use
our Center in lumira Park and oh yeah I
mean it was great me Justin went the
first day and we talked to Franny pulled
him and told him this is what we're
looking for and I think the first time
me and Justin James saw that really okay
I think we found her a girl and yeah
they opened up her door there their
doors we had open auditions actually he
brought in Simone and she's saying for
us oh my goodness it was I think it was
after that moment we're like okay I
think we're good we we found her we
found her Camila Simone do you remember
that first meeting and what you were
doing were you in school had you been
acting what were you doing when you
first met these guys well it was during
the summer vacation and I was doing a
summer program with them and so they
came into each classes to see all the
students that were working in the
classes and they said oh we're doing
this film and we're looking for this
this and that
so I had a friend who's sitting next to
me and her friends were like oh you'll
probably get it you you're perfect for
that I was like whatever and so and so I
wasn't really thinking about like oh
probably an audition for this or you
know I wasn't really thinking that much
about it and then my friend over there
she was like this oh my gosh that's
justin chon and I said Who so I've never
seen tilite so I didn't know who he was
it's just like this he's hot and I was
like what is wrong it's just like I
totally want to work on the movie with
him so I could see him every day and I
was like okay that's nice and so I went
into the I went into the audition with
them oh yeah and mr. Fernando Pullum
asked me to go into a room and sing for
them
I guess that one ball
something hit okay it raised hairs on
the back row like that yeah I remember
that moment still okay that's good
and when I went into the audition I just
did what felt natural and felt like what
was good for the character and it was
actually my birthday that day and later
that later that day they called me so
those the perfect birthday present that
is the perfect birthday present so you
get the perfect birthday present which
is gonna be in this movie and then you
start talking to Justin about what he's
gonna ask you to do in this film what
were the scenes that you found kind of
the most scary beforehand did they turn
out to be the scenes that were the
hardest to film as he's describing the
movie to you um probably the scenes that
were most scary to me before when I was
just reading the script was when I was
supposed to when I was supposed to be
like when I was supposed to die at the
end so I was thinking that I was like oh
no oh no this is bad
I was just thinking I don't know I don't
know how I'm gonna do this it was
actually probably the hardest scene
because my mom is like no you can't act
like that you have to be dead you you
can't because sometimes my resting face
is a smile I don't know and so to me I
felt like I was smiling when I was dead
so it was kind of hard for me so and mom
was okay with the language she's like
mom there could be some bad words in
this like every mom actually coached me
with the language so okay we'll be
talking to mom afterward about that but
you can see how Simone is very very like
very proper and speak very well and I
remember being on set and I was standing
next to her mother watching the monitor
and she's cussing up a storm during the
scene and look over at Luke over a chair
to go I'm so sorry everyone's your
daughter's innocence with our movie ante
I want to talk a little bit about the
look of this film
was it first of all where did you in
just in me and was this very first
conversation is leave your color film
home because this is black and white I
had the thesis that I was showing
a Film Festival and that's where Justin
saw and reached out he liked the stout
reach out to me and then yeah it was his
vision from the very beginning to have
him black and white I think I think he's
secretly wanted to make the film like
very hard to sell you know with the
title starring asian-americans and then
black and white but the the real reason
that with we sat down with Alex and
James we're gonna figure out like we
couldn't like actually afford color like
you know with with a little bit of film
during period doing black and white just
a real pure way to have a more timeless
look and to see into a story at one
there of less distractions over getting
everything purely correct and then
matching like oh look our temperatures
everything so it's just more effective
way to shoot in terms of physical
photography when you are on location are
you maybe grabbing a shot that you don't
quite have a permit for how are you
making sure that you're getting bang for
your minimum bucks
nobody's here again there's no film
office people the first so when we've
signed my hopes in in gardena the
landlord actually told us they're like
oh the Gardena permit is very expensive
and it takes a while to get we have an
idea to work around it
let's pretend that you guys are a
landscaping company and that you guys
are doing yard work in front of the
building we're like you sure that's okay
like yeah should be fine like okay
that's fine we'll go with it so the
first week obviously we were the
production and we're renovating the
whole building so there was some
landscaping going on and then we started
filming and then a week into like the
Gardena is like city officials would
calm down what do you guys doing was
like oh we're uh you know we're mowing
the lawn stuff and they're like what are
the cameras for like we're doing like
before-and-after shots and then you came
to set with a leaf blower right I got it
guys you know and then a week after
they're like we know you're filming
we're like okay what do we have
you do this and this I was like alright
we'll do that like you know like the gig
is up you guys have to go get a permit
okay fine we'll go get it David there
are so many projects that have been
coming out in the last year or so and
probably will continue to come out about
the riots but they're not a lot of
projects that are looking at this
episode in American in Los Angeles
history through the lens of
korean-americans
so did you guys talk about why this was
a story that not only hadn't been told
but why it needed to be told from the
very beginning what were the
conversations about why this film was
important in terms of the narrative that
has been constructed around the riots I
mean well first and foremost like Justin
already knew ahead of time and we all
knew ahead of time there were gonna be
other la riot films coming out and so
with us in a low-budget film we had to
beat them to the punch you know and that
was actually a huge motivation for it
and a lot of the times too when it comes
to the Korean American spirits people
don't talk about it actually we're not
even a part of the table to even have
that conversation financially speaking
our businesses were destroyed if you can
look back at clips you'll see store
owners on top of building shooting
people down because they were trying to
murder them and Korean Americans aren't
even talked about it in this kind of
sense you know like I remember as a kid
- like people were telling me the people
that were protecting the stores or
actually like Korean mafia members
because their parents owned these stores
and they were trying to protect their
family but we're not even brought to the
table for this conversation and it was
such a I like you know you don't really
understand and there's you know the the
the black American perspective the white
American perspective but our perspective
isn't told and so and that kind of sense
like Justin really did want to make sure
that it was put out there and people
understood what was going on not just
for to other communities but another one
as well well I know it's a hard movie to
make but I'm really glad not only that
you made it but you brought it and
shared it with us